and finally new rule I'm all for
rallying around the flag but let's not
rally around the guy who missed all the
red flags yeah America has been slow and
inefficient and responding to this
crisis and yet our leaders approval
rating is up because that's what we do
in times of crisis our leaders get a
bump in the polls whether it's justified
or not because of crisis is no time to
think and rallying around the president
is just one of those irrational things
we do in a crisis like hoarding Charmin
or praying especially if the president
says he's a wartime leader which this
president says he is now unfortunately
that is a war on science you know
Americans have made this mistake before
on September 11th 2001 as President Bush
was reading my pet goat to school
children an aide whispered in his ear
America is under attack
and he sat there looking like he forgot
to turn off the stove his response was
the attack and wait let's find out what
happened to the goat and then of course
because America Bush's approval rating
went up after the attack the bush people
much like the Trump people now said who
could have imagined this well in both
cases experts yeah experts did Bush was
repeatedly warned that al Qaeda could
crash a plane into the Pentagon and the
FBI reported that weird holy men were
training at us flight schools practicing
the flying part no interest in landings
and then there was the famous memo
entitled bin Laden determined to strike
in u.s. Veronica Mars could have put
this together in 40 minutes al Qaeda did
everything but send Bush an email that
said September 11th save the date now
was this current crisis preventable not
all of it of course but we could have
done what South Korea did their
nightmare
started the exact same day ours did but
while Trump shut up experts happy talked
and lied his ass off South Korea put a
strong testing program into place and
tracing people and today they have 21
times few of the cases and 30 times
fewer deaths they didn't have to do a
big lockdown like we do so their pets
aren't always looking at them alike
don't you have someplace to be if this
is a war Trump lost it in January he's
not FDR or JFK
he's lol so it's more than a little
disturbing but he's getting a bump in
the polls from all this a bump which
tells us where once again entering into
rally around the leader time around the
guy who made it worse I mean come on
toilet paper is now more valuable than
the dollar we do have actual heroes here
they're working in hospitals doctors on
the front lines
stalkers at grocery stores and cashiers
at weed dispensaries but not Trump let's
stop doing this thing where we delude
ourselves into lionizing someone just
because they were there when the [ __ ]
hit the fan Giuliani was not popular in
New York before 9/11 and then we had a
crisis and soon he was America's mayor
New York Magazine said people yearn to
experience his presence
yes his wives not so much and for the
last two decades Rudy has travelled the
world as an international security
expert despite the fact that his big
security decision as mayor was to
override objections from the NYPD and
the Secret Service and put the city's
emergency command center in the one
place it was most likely to be wiped out
in the World Trade Center after it had
been bombed the first time it would be
like stationing your tonight tornado
response team inside a trailer park the
root problem we got here
his republicans are better at politics
and so they get elected but once in
office they can't do anything because
their idea of government is dismantling
government so let's also skip the we
need to be less partisan virtue
signaling when it's obvious Republicans
have a proud proven legacy of government
dysfunction syndrome
yesterday it was Bush and Giuliani today
it's Trump and McConnell and Ron
DeSantis and we can only be safer when
every last one of them is voted out
you